I've become a bathroom celebrity I go in
the bathroom I have like women like slow
cuts like it's an 80s movie and they're
like what you just for my grandma or my
daughter didn't want to use a cane or
seeing you have such a sense of humor
Selma's been getting support from her
Hollywood friends sarah michelle gellar
started a meal trained Reese Witherspoon
and Constance Zimmer are on it want more
inspiration some a son Arthur says quote
mommy's not sick mommy's brave I don't
really like it and then he grew up I
love this kid he's so well-adjusted it
took me 44 years to get where he is at
seven he's very empathetic and very
grounded sense of humor and it was great
hair it's good looking this week's cover
girl also sat down with people TV the 47
year old is still working her new
Netflix sci-fi series another life
starts streaming tomorrow but you better
believe Selma makes time for fun with
this guy he's funny we played dodgeball
but I don't dodge cuz that could be so
dangerous
I don't move side to side like perfect
so I get to just hit him and then he
throws back to me and he thinks it's
amazing it feels good
[Music]